First time at Google.
So welcome.
Thank you.
This is amazing.
So tell us a little bit how you got started on your blog.
Um,
well my husband John and I started the blog in 2012 I had been blogging,
um,
kind of in another space or on another website for a couple of years and it just
never really did well.
Um,
it was kind of a lifestyle blog and it was kind of my training wheels and I
started the more recipes and people really started to resonate with that.
And so once we kind of figured out what was working and what wasn't working with
that blog,
um,
I just kind of came up with the idea to make a blog that kind of represented the
way that I cooked at home,
which is extremely simple.
I'm kind of lazy,
kind of impatient as most people are.
And most of the times I would go to a food blog and I would love the photo,
love the idea,
and I would see ingredients that I could never find.
And it took two hours and I just was never going to make it.
And so that's kind of the heart of our blog.
That's where it came from.
Um,
and the reason that we decided to call it minimalist Baker is because we were
also getting really into like simple living in minimalism at the time.
And I have a sweet tooth,
so that's kind of where the name came from.
Um,
and I think that people are drawn to websites that they know what the messages
right away when they come.
Like you don't want to have to search to find out what this person is about,
which is why we decided to make all the recipes 10 ingredients or last 30
minutes or less or one bowl.
Um,
and that's huge really how I cook when I make us dinners.
So,
um,
yeah,
so we've been doing it now for four years,
full time for three years.
And John does all the techie design,
Google things and I just jumped here with us today to say hi John.
Welcome.
Yeah.
So your new book is specifically focused in that space.
Yes.
So the book,
basically our readers started asking us for something that they could get food
on.
I cook from that didn't require an iPad or their iPhone out.
And so we've been doing that for,
or we started working on that in early 2015 and um,
it's called minimal stickers,
everyday cooking.
And I kind of wanted it to be a collection of breakfast,
lunch,
dinner,
sides,
desserts,
so that it truly is kind of covers all the basis in terms of,
you know,
what you would want to cook from your kitchen on everyday basis.
Sorry.
And we're going to try a couple of those recipes today.
Yes.
So what are we going to have?
So,
um,
we're going to try to recipes.
I'm the first one is a southwest sweet potato,
black bean dip.
It's good for it.
And you guys do sports.
Do you guys watch sporting events?
It'd be really great for that.
We don't watch sports,
but we liked it and it's not required.
Yeah.
And that one I believe comes together in like 30 minutes.
Yes.
And it's gluten free.
Very,
very simple.
And then the other one is a butternut squash pasta.
Um,
there are so many ways that you can make alternative sauces.
if you're dairy free,
if you're Vegan,
I have lactose intolerance.
So that's kind of why I started experimenting with alternative sauces and I
didn't write the book on that.
This is kind of like my inspired version and I actually have since created more
sauce recipes that I gravitate more toward.
But this one is excellent for fall and you get a whole serving of vegetables
with your pasta.
So it's kind of Nice space and you do quite a bit of Vegan cooking as well.
Yeah,
that's become the focus for the blog because I'm lactose intolerance and I'm was
mostly eating vegetarian anyways.
Um,
and I love experimenting with egg free and dairy free baking.
That's kind of has become the focus for the blog and most people know us for
Vegan gluten free things.
Fabulous.
We'll let's go.
Okay,
let's do it.
So we're going to start with the dip and kind of the first thing you want to do,
make sure you've rinsed off your sweet potato,
which I assume they have absolutely can confirm sweet potatoes plan.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
And you're just going to kind of,
you don't have to remove the skin or anything.
I'm just chop it up and you're just going to one of,
kind of cut it into bite sized cubes.
Being very careful.
Obviously
I have accidentally cut myself before.
I think if you haven't accidentally cut yourself,
I'm not cooking and math,
you're like not the real deal.
My chef teammates tell me a good cut is your first like real badge of honor and
a kitchens.
Yeah,
quite a chicken.
I tried to avoid it,
but they tell me how it makes you really super religious.
So feel,
feel safe in math.
Yeah.
John usually comes down to check on all my injuries during the day.
Like I burned myself again.
He's like,
stop doing that.
It's like it's part of the kid badges of honor.
Just on her.
Yeah.
So I think,
um,
I kind of learned early on that there is a big difference in,
especially with sweet potatoes when it comes to organic and nonorganic the
flavor and the texture of organic sweet potatoes is in majorly better than
nonorganic.
And I'm sure you're all very smart,
intelligent people and you probably know that organic produce is better,
but,
um,
just for the sheer sake of flavor,
organic sweet potatoes are so,
so much better and you don't have to add as much,
you know,
oil and salt and sweet near to them because they're just naturally already
tasting a lot better.
Are there other um,
produce items you feel strongly are significantly better from a taste
perspective when organic?
I think most of the squashes are actually,
um,
I can usually tell a big difference with apples and strawberries especially just
you know,
things that are in season are going to taste better as well.
Um,
so yeah,
but mostly I think the biggest one has been sweet potatoes actually.
So all is you're going to do is just drizzle on a little bit of cooking oil.
I usually use like melted coconut oil at home cause it's a really nice source of
healthy fats.
And then all you're going to see his knees with is a little bit of salts and
Maple Syrup just to kind of bring out their sweetness a little bit more.
Just drizzle that on
our flat top.
Just wants to talk to you first.
I'm sorry.
They're
supposed to be a safety feature is often an annoyance feature I can say from
personal experience.
And then this is just cumin,
Chili powder,
sin and cinnamon,
which enhances the flavor even more,
adds a little bit of spice.
So a little bit of salty,
sweet,
savory spice mixed.
Love it.
You don't really have to add a lot of sweet potatoes because they're already so
delicious.
Um,
but this just kind of enhances their flavor and make some pop in the actual dip.
So you're going to roast these for about 20 minutes at three 75 or just until
they're tender.
Um,
because we don't have that much time.
We already have some rusted through the magic of preparation.
So
while we did at you guys,
um,
came out perfectly.
I'm so impressed.
I mean,
I didn't even do this so I can't take the credit.
But yeah,
essentially the rest of the dip is very simple.
I'm going to go ahead and put these ingredients in here and then we'll look up
the sauce.
This is just fresh corn.
You can also use canned corn if you can't find a whole corn on the cob.
And then this is just diced red onion,
black beans.
You could also use pinto beans,
um,
or other beans.
Or if you don't like beans,
keen walk would actually be an excellent substitution.
And then just a little bit of fresh Cilantro.
So that makes up the bulk of,
can I set things on here?
Okay.
It might be,
if it beeps,
we'll just tell it to stop.
Yeah.
Oh,
I think I will actually use this both for the sauce.
So we are going to,
essentially the sauce is just a slightly saucy or guacamole and I kind of like
to have the avocado and then cut it in cubes so it smashes up a lot easier.
Usually a few knock it,
it comes off.
Make sure you don't cut your hand that you've not be good.
Yeah,
I don't think I want that.
Another badge of honor at Google today on camera as so once it's cubed you can
just kind of scoop it out like so
you can be fancy and use a potato Masher I like just using a fork cause I think
it's faster
and you can usually tell if the avocado is ripe.
Obviously it's soft,
but also when you buy it,
there's usually a little,
um,
I don't know what it's called,
like stem at the top.
And if you take it off and it's green,
that means it's still fresh and it's going to be good because sometimes you open
avocado and it's brown in it.
Makes sure we're just ruined your day,
you know?
And that can also help you avoid squeezing them.
So everyone else who comes through doesn't get bruised stuff.
Avocados.
Yeah.
So you're just going to mash up your avocado.
It doesn't have to be perfect.
You can actually,
if you like,
kind of the chunkier guacamole texture,
you could just leave a lot of it whole.
Um,
and so yeah,
we're also going to be adding some lime juice.
I have a fancy juicer at home,
but before I had a juicer,
I just kind of stuck a fork in there and juice it out like this.
It's just adds a little bit of acidity to the dip.
Since we have quite a bit of sweetness going on with the sweet potatoes,
it also helps keep the avocado from browning.
Okay.
And then we're also just going to add a pinch of salt and a little bit of olive
oil just to send it out.
Phew.
Trying to avoid fats.
That's optional.
You don't have to.
And then just a tiny bit more of,
you can use a Ga bay nectar here or just maple syrup.
I think it just kind of,
I don't know.
In most of the sauces that I make,
I like to have a acidity and saltiness and a little bit of sweetness,
which is why I like adding the maple syrup in there
so you can just kind of taste as you go.
Um,
this is looking just about right and now we're just going to,
Oh,
I lost my mixing bowls,
my mixing spoons.
Certain we have more.
Perfect.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
And you can make this step ahead of time.
It would actually be,
I think the flavor kind of gets better the longer it marinades.
Okay.
Once it's kind of mixed together you can taste it and see if it needs more lime
juice,
more solid,
more maple syrup.
I'm usually adding more of all these things,
um,
because I like big flavorful dishes and then we're just going to finish it with
a little bit more fresh Cilantro and just kind of for some more color.
And
that's essentially it.
I'm just going to scoop some into my serving dish here.
Cilantro is sometimes a controversial ingredient here at Google as as many
people I think in general have a reaction in a bad way to the taste.
Is there another herb you might recommend or another garnish might play with if
you say wanted to avoid Cilantro?
Um,
yeah.
John doesn't like Cilantro so I know the struggle is real in our house.
It's real.
Real here.
Likes how many people don't like Cilantro here.
Okay.
So sorry.
No,
how to throw for who to throw food out later.
Um,
you could easily just leave out saunter to be honest,
it's not a key ingredient.
You could also use parsley.
Mint might actually add a nice flavor,
um,
really kind of whatever you have on hand.
But if you have like an adversity to salon show,
you might not like the taste of other herbs as well.
Like maybe parsley would be too similar.
So maybe just leave it out.
If so,
feel free to leave it out or as we tried to do here,
you could put it on this side and then your guests could perhaps that.
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh,
well it's in the dip.
So sorry about that guys.
We already mixed it.
Totally fine.
So you can serve that.
I'm actually,
I just made this,
her finance today and she just ate it like a Burrito bowl with a fork.
But usually I serve it with chips.
Um,
that's,
yeah,
that's our first raising to me.
Um,
okay,
so pasta shall we?
Yeah.
So,
okay.
How many of you guys have made a Vegan like cheese sauce?
Oh,
you guys experts.
I know what I'm working with here.
Okay.
So,
uh,
personally I like to use kind of like the cheaper almond milk that you get at
the store because if you get too high of quality of almond milk,
the flavor if of the almonds is way too strong.
I kind of like using the cheapo ones that you know,
like are a dollar a carton because they're kind of mostly water.
Um,
but for kind of the sake of showing you guys what a nut milk looks like,
I sometimes make my own at home.
It is quite simple.
Um,
you basically can just make your own at home in that way you can control how
much water is in it and you can control the flavor and you don't have to add
sweeteners,
which oftentimes is brands do.
So this is just one cup of soaked almonds.
You can soak them overnight and cold water.
Or if you're in a hurry,
which I usually am because I forget,
uh,
you can just pour,
I'm really hot water over them,
let them soak for an hour and they're good to go.
Okay.
And this is five cups of filtered water
and it's going to get very loud.
There we go.
Here we go.
So normally I would let that go for about a minute or two.
Really.
The longer you blend your nut milks,
the more um,
kind of meat you're going to get out of it and the creamy or your sauces are
going to be.
And so,
um,
but the sake of time I will go ahead and pour it out.
Usually what I do is that you can buy nut milk bags.
Do you guys know what those are?
No.
Okay.
You guys are so cool.
Um,
I don't actually have a nut milk bag,
so I'm not that fancy.
I just put like a really thin,
clean towel over and mixing bowl and just pour it over.
Uh,
but today we're going to use this kind of sieve contraption here and you're
essentially just trying to get out any of the extra,
um,
bits of almonds that may be left behind because that makes sure not milk tastes
gritty and that's not what we want.
So you can see kind of at this stage or when you're blending,
you can add dates to sweeten our maple syrup or add vanilla if you want to have
like vanilla almond milk.
But since we're going to be making a savory sauce today,
you don't really want any of that extra sweetness.
Um,
and of course you can use other nuts as well.
I think he's will not to be great.
You can make oatmeal,
you can make hemp seed milk.
Um,
it's the same general principle.
So similar methodology,
different route ingredient.
Yeah.
Um,
you don't need to soak things like oats for as long as nuts,
just because nuts are kind of hard and um,
you need to soak them to open them up and get the flavor on.
So yeah.
And then you have about four to five cups of almond milk and that will keep in
the fridge for a few days.
I think I'm just gonna set this over here.
I feel incredibly lazy for purchasing almond milk if it's really,
I mean,
I still purchase almond milk.
I just,
I think that it's nice to know how to make it because I honestly think the taste
is better.
Um,
but you,
you know,
for the average person who's working all day and you needed to go home at night,
like he don't need to be making your own if you don't want to.
Okay.
So do you guys know how to cut up butternut squash is,
yes.
Have you guys done that?
It's dangerous.
It's super dangerous.
I had,
I watched him.
Do you have tips?
I would love it.
I watched a youtube video like three times before I attempted it,
so I didn't hurt myself.
Um,
butternut squash is just pretty firm.
and so they're kind of difficult to peel,
but essentially all you want to do is cut off the top and the bottom so you have
a stable base.
And then I also like to cut off the bulb from the kind of skinny top part.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then you want to peel it,
which you can do a with a vegetable peeler.
I don't,
I've never used this one,
so we'll see how this goes.
I actually kind of just prefer using the knife.
I think it's a lot easier.
You have more control.
Okay.
Um,
it's butternut squash I think is the most difficult,
but you can,
I think it's also equally difficult to do pumpkin sometimes.
Um,
but the more you do it,
the really it's so much easier it gets and it's not that difficult.
And I use butternut squash a lot during the fall.
Um,
kind of when it's in season and really fresh.
And then you just want to scoop out the seeds,
which I will attempt to do with the spoon.
But you can also do this with kind of like a melon baller that might actually be
easier,
perhaps that robust,
that might work a little bit better.
Now you're essentially just trying to get all the seeds out
and there's a lot of seeds.
So I might actually just do a half.
You actually only need two cups of,
he would butternut squash for this.
If you're in a super big hurry like I was yesterday,
you can despite cubed butternut squash at the store.
Um,
but for those of you who might get like CSA boxes or if you just want to know
kind of how to do it,
it is nice to know that it's very easy to do at home and you probably saved
money that way as well.
Does anybody have any questions for Dana while she's diligently getting the
squash?
So for that,
for our TV audience,
the question is what do you do with the almond pulp once it's strained?
You can do a lot of things with the almond pope.
Um,
you can dry it out in the oven and then add it to baked goods.
for instance,
like banana breads really easy to make gluten free.
So that's what I ended up doing a,
the times is just kind of dragging it out and keeping it on hand.
You can also add it just like it is two things.
Like say I'm
a date based desserts,
which are some of my favorite vegan desserts.
Just blend up some dates,
throw in the almond pulp,
throwing in some nuts and Roman to balls and they're like little energy bites.
That way,
you're not wasting any part of the almond,
which is nice.
Um,
if you just write out and the oven,
I think it just like three 50 for,
I don't know,
15 to 20 minutes.
You don't want it to start looking like burnt or brown.
You just want to basically remove the moisture from it.
And then you have kind of like the almond milk that you buy at the store.
Um,
it has been processed slightly differently,
but it's this,
it's the same exact texture.
Um,
and then I think that's the easiest thing you can do with it.
and then you can just kind of,
the way that I make things gluten free is sub in oat flour,
almond meal and a gluten free blend.
Um,
and that usually takes the place of the all purpose flour and favorite gluten
free blend cause there's a lot of them.
Yeah.
So I have my unblend,
um,
that I use on the blog,
but is in terms of store bought,
I really like Bob's red mill,
their new one to one gluten free baking blend is pretty,
it's pretty spot on.
It has a really nice light,
airy texture and it has a nice blend of ingredients.
Um,
and yeah,
that tends to be my go to.
So does anybody else have any favorite gluten-free blends?
I'm,
there's always more that I haven't tried.
Yeah.
Bob's,
it's pretty good.
They kind of have it figured out.
I've also heard good things about the,
I think it's called Cup for cup.
Yeah.
And he's that one to great effect,
but it's certainly a selectively in terms of what I'm making.
Right?
Yeah.
And I think that one is a little bit more pricey too,
so,
um,
likely.
So there's,
there's so many great blogs now that are s like just strictly gluten free,
um,
in terms of like baking and you can go and try a million different blends.
The one that I have is a pretty good all purpose blend.
Um,
but I've been trying new ones from other sites as well and there's just like a
lot of really beautiful blends out there for different purposes.
Okay.
So we have most,
we'll just call it good.
We have most of the squash cubes and you're just going to add a little bit of
oil.
Again,
I would probably use coconut oil or avocado at home,
a little bit of salt and we're going to throw it in there right along that side.
The sweet potatoes and betterness.
Squash doesn't take that long to bake,
usually only like 15 to 20 minutes.
And you're just looking for a soft texture.
Like when you put Polka fork in,
it should fall out,
which we have here isn't just
um,
so I'm just going to saute up some garlic to add some kick to the sauce and
because we're going to be blending and it doesn't have to be finally a minster.
Anything,
just kind of a loose chop so it gets evenly cooked and we're just going to add a
little bit of olive oil to the pan.
I believe a few tablespoons going off of memory here.
No we are,
I haven't tried this recipe with roasted garlic,
but I would think it would pair really well with the flavors of the
squash.
It's going to rinse this off.
So,
as I'm sure most of you guys know,
you aren't looking for like burnt garlic because that's an awful flavor.
You're just looking for it to be slightly browned,
not should only take a couple of minutes.
Kind of while that's happening,
I think I will go ahead and add my squash to the blender.
Um,
you don't have to have a nice high speed blender.
You could probably do this in a food processor,
but I just kind of like,
um,
the texture that highspeed blenders give sauces because there's like zero
grittiness,
um,
which can kind of be a problem sometimes with Vegan sausages.
Um,
we're also going to add nutritional yeast.
This is,
I actually,
I don't even know what nutrition nutritional yeast is.
I know that it has be 12 it and it tastes like cheese
and it's,
I call it fairy dust for,
for vegans.
Um,
uh,
we're also going to be adding some salt to the sauce and a bit of pepper.
Um,
and I also like to add in some Vegan parmesan cheese,
which is basically just raw cashews,
nutritional yeast,
garlic powder and sea salt.
And it ends up tasting an incredible amount,
like real parmesan cheese and I basically put it on everything.
We're also going to add a little bit of vegetable broth.
Umm,
if you don't have broth you can just sub all almond milk and an unsweetened
planed almond milk.
If you have an allergy,
you could also sub rice milk.
I would probably stay away from soy milk because it has kind of an intense
flavor.
And let's just pretend that this is perfectly,
it's really brown.
You have to,
because it is really,
really brown.
I would probably let it go a couple more minutes,
but I kind of liked the flavor of raw garlic as well,
so that's fine depending on the,
how much do you like spicy food?
I guess we'll turn this baby off.
Well,
yeah,
we're good.
We're good.
You can also throw in a little red pepper flake,
which I usually prefer.
Um,
you can also add chili garlic sauce.
you don't need much of this because it's quite strong,
but because the butternut squash,
when it rose up,
it gets a tiny bit sweet.
I just feel that it needs to be offset with something a little bit spicier
and when you're bundling it,
you'll kind of be able to tell how thick the sauce is getting.
Right now it's looking more of like a puree,
so I'm just going to add in the rest of my almond milk and a little bit more
broth.
You're looking for a thick but pourable consistency.
Okay.
That's looking just about right and I just realized I need the cooktop again,
so we're just trying to put it back on the stove to warm it up.
It's ready as it is,
but just to kind of heated up and develop the flavors a little bit more.
It is still looking a little bit thick,
so I might add in just a tiny bit more of my water or almond milk is fine too.
The colors beautiful.
It's reminiscent of beloved Mac and cheese.
That's kind of the great thing about using vegetable purees as the base for your
sauces is because they add such a color that looks like there's actually cheese
in it when there's not.
So yeah,
I think I'm just going to grab a little bit more water and thin it down a little
bit
and you're just going to warm that up and I'm looking for a whisk.
Yeah.
So you're just going to kind of heat it up.
And while this is happening,
cooking some pasta.
I'm eating gluten free at the moment,
so I usually am going for a gluten free pasta,
which I've actually been very impressed with the quality of a gluten free passes
that you can find at the store now.
It's like they're undetectable gluten free,
which is great.
That's big progress.
It is big progress.
Do you have a favorite specifically from a brand perspective?
So trader Joe's has a great organic brown rice and Chenwa um,
pasta,
which um,
I really think it doesn't taste like,
I don't think it tastes much different then.
Maybe I'll try that.
Yeah,
if you like it silly,
I think it's good.
If you let it sit too long,
it can kind of get a little bit gummy.
It's true.
Regular Pasta too though,
or pasta too.
Um,
and yeah.
Then you're just going to add in your cooked pasta and give it a toss and you're
basically good to go.
Um,
the only other things I would add as a garnish here would be more Vegan parmesan
cheese because I always put more vegan.
Parmesan cheese on my pasta is,
it just adds a lot more flavor.
Um,
but yeah,
that's essentially,
it
smells amazing.
If you can't smell it where you're sitting,
I can tell you it smells amazing.
And the sauce to pasta ratio is probably a little bit heavy,
but I kind of personally like that.
So
thanks there.
And then,
yeah,
just kind of finish it up with some garnishes just to make it look a little bit
more pretty.
Um,
if you are interested in another more,
I guess I have developed more pasta sauces since this recipe that I almost like
a little bit more just by making that pasta.
This pasta is wonderful and beautiful and special,
but if you had other pastas you might like them.
Also,
there's a lot of,
um,
I have a lot of Mac and cheese recipes on the site using different things.
So you can experiment with a lot of different bases,
but this is great for fall and it's great to get a serving of vegetables with
your pasta.
So I love it.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Does anybody
have any questions for Dana?
How do you balance your love of food and having to maintain a blog to promote it
and really the upkeep aspect of running a blog professionally.
Sure.
Um,
well I genuinely do love cooking and developing recipes and eating all day.
And so I think that you kind of have to have a heart for it.
Um,
as I'm sure most people who do it would be able to confirm.
But I also make sure that,
and John always encourages me just to make the things that I'm interested in
making and the things that I love.
Otherwise it can feel really constraining,
um,
to like you,
you want to,
you know,
make our recipe that gets good search traffic.
Well,
like is that actually what you get excited about in the morning?
So generally the things that I'm making during the week or the recipes that I
schedule out are ones that I am really interested in trying.
Like I love Mac and cheese.
So how can I make that for vegans?
Or how can I make that,
um,
tastes just as good as the real thing.
So it sounds like authenticity.
Yeah.
He like,
you have to really love what you're doing and not get too worried about forcing
it to make it successful.
Yeah.
And the further you get along,
like we've been doing it for four years,
it is sometimes hard to remember that.
And it can be a struggle some days like,
oh,
this is a business.
It's not fun anymore.
But we,
it's just the two of us and we have a lot of fun and we love working at home and
I love cooking.
So it's,
it's usually pretty easy to keep that in mind.
Do you have formal culinary training and then how would you more specifically
recommend like Vegan culinary training so you don't have to see your point
called compromise your principles to get traditional culinary training?
I don't have traditional culinary training.
I've worked in a humorous,
the number of restaurants,
like probably 20 restaurants.
I've been a server and a host and I've been,
I'm also prepared foods that I did get a really good handle on cooking that way.
And then I'm watching the food network,
honestly just learning like how does Emeril Lagasse chop an onion?
And then I would try it.
Um,
and then just a lot of experimentation.
I have wondered about going to culinary school,
but like you said,
I don't know if I would want to do it.
The traditional route of having to learn how to make butter sauces because I
personally couldn't try it or if I'm gluten free,
I don't know if I could try like a souffle.
Um,
but I did just butchering aspect I imagine would be a huge turnout.
Yeah.
But I think that more and more programs are understanding that.
And I actually just spoke with a friend who went to a culinary program in New
York City that was fused with nutrition and she's Vegan and at the time she was
being,
when she went through the program.
And,
um,
they were able to kind of accommodate for all the different students diets,
which was very encouraging to me because prior to that,
I didn't think that you could go to culinary school without doing the
traditional,
the traditional kind of French methods of like the butchering and the cheese
sauces in the F souffle's and those types of things.
So I think that if you do some research,
there are definitely options.
Um,
and even in a city like Portland where we live,
there are a number of restaurants that do cooking classes and there's businesses
that are solely based around teaching people,
um,
cooking.
So I haven't done any research on if there's Vegan options,
but I'm sure there there are,
yeah.
Like tips for the experimentation process and any,
any guard rails that can help abort fails.
And then how do you manage your fails?
Yeah.
Um,
John is good to remind me that it's all experimentation,
so he'll come down like,
oh,
my recipes fail today and I had to throw them away,
but compost them hope.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
definitely composting them.
Yeah.
It's just a part of the process.
I mean I kind of see what I do as the learning what doesn't work.
So you kind of don't have to do that at home.
Um,
but you know,
I would say for every recipe I try,
I'm testing it two to three times and that means that the first two times just
aren't,
it just didn't go well or maybe I have something in mind and I just can't figure
it out.
And so I just set it aside for the day because I've tried it five times and it
didn't work.
Um,
so that's,
yeah,
it's just part of the process and hopefully you can find reliable blogs out
there that kind of see you in the right direction.
Um,
and there are more and more blogs all the time specifically focusing on gluten
free cooking,
plant based cooking.
So I think it's getting easier to become vegan and gluten free.
Maybe use those as a jumping off point.
Yeah.
Experimentation.
Yeah,
that's what I do,
frankly.
I look at five different ways somebody said to do something and core elements
that can be combined and figure it must be important.
I use those.
Yeah,
exactly.
Cause I always like to don't want to feel constrained by it but I also know you
know people like Dana or are failing for us in that regard.
So I try to acknowledge that and use that to my benefit.
And I think it's helpful too when you're trying to attempt something.
Say like uh,
like a cheese sauce it,
this one isn't a great example of it but the one,
the newest one on the blog the best,
I think it's called the best gluten free Mac and cheese or Vegan Mac and cheese.
I just went and looked at like how does the best French chef make a cheese
sauce?
And then I just tried to mock that.
But with Vegan ingredients,
I think that it's really helpful on recipes like that where you,
you kind of want to know what the basics are.
You want to know what the foundational principles are so that when you go to
attempt it you kind of have some frame of mind you're in.
You're not just like throwing a bunch of stuff in the blender and hoping it
turns out.
I think you can at least follow like a methodology stuff.
Right,
right.
I usually go to like [inaudible] Garten and out in brown because they,
they know and they've tested and they've tried and they're like seasoned chefs.
Like that way I kind of have some type of path to go off of when I'm trying to
veganize something or make it gluten free.
I Kenji Lopez all is great too cause he speaks really about the why behind why
recipes work and you can use that for experimentation because you won't take out
those core elements.
Right.
That are make or break best recommendations for someone transitioning off of
dairy.
Yes.
Vegan Parmesan cheese I think is a huge life saver because I used to put
parmesan cheese on everything and then it was just stripped away in my life
wasn't complete.
So what life was it Seamus?
Yeah.
So once I realized like,
oh I can still make cheese sauces,
I can still have pizza.
Like I bring my Parmesan Shaker to the restaurants.
It's very tacky.
Like,
oh no,
wait,
I have my own,
I think in Portland,
in the bay area,
you can get away with that for sure.
Yeah.
Well I'm,
and in Portland sometimes you go to pizza shops and they have nutritional use on
the counter.
So it makes it a lot easier.
You are not alone testing out a lot of or just trying out a lot of the different
um,
dairy alternatives.
Like,
um,
diet cheese is great.
I know some people don't love it,
but I think it's kind of an acquired taste.
And then the further I get away from having had cheese,
I kind of forget what it was like.
Um,
but it just takes time,
like any breakup.
But the good thing is,
is that a lot of companies are putting more and more plant based items on the
market and there's amazing Vegan cheeses now that like our soft cheeses and hard
cheeses that genuinely do you taste like the real thing.
Um,
and of course all the different nut milks you can make.
I don't miss,
you know,
dairy because there's coconut milk,
ice cream and I can put the Parmesan cheese on my pizza.
And,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
there's definitely some things that I miss,
but I think that there are so many alternatives.
Um,
so I think just like finding out what,
um,
what are the things that you missed most about it?
And then trying to find substitutions.
Like I really missed ice cream,
so that's why I have so many ice cream recipes on the blog.
There's like 15 or something.
So it sounds good to me.
Yeah.
Well,
thank you so much for joining us.
I'm glad you were able to come to Google and especially to share this with all,
all of us today.
Yeah.
Thanks for having me.